so in bottom beats just not rhythmic
elements commonly because of that
you want the listener to lose track of
time as it were to further sink into
the actual effect of the thing so
musically there's generally just kind of
textural things some people use nature
sounds and stuff
it is interesting how the musical
quality works as a sort of observation
of the technical element in some way so
you sort of aren't really
focused on that as much you're listening
to the top layer in the bottom layers
doing all the dirty work
corey bloody allen in the building how
are you friend
i'm good man how's your achilles it's
slowly
reattaching my leg to my foot which is
what i wanted i've been walking around
for quite a while in flip-flops in dubai
to which my physiotherapist said cut
them up and throw them in the bin
immediately
um but yeah i'm back i'm back in the uk
a little bit of a tan
and ready to get back on the rehab this
sounds like a coming-of-age
novel flip-flops in dubai
it is i found myself and it was a proper
pair of shoes
nice man well i'm glad it's healing i
just remembered that as
as we started here yeah it was a serious
uh
a serious setback but honestly man the
i found a level of fortitude that kind
of came out of me that i didn't even
know existed
it was so bizarre i thought
i don't know i thought i knew it was
like opening a door inside of a house
i'd lived in my entire life
that to a room that i didn't know
existed and
um very much kind of found a level of
resilience
that was almost like it was almost
endogenous it almost surfaced when it
was needed
um in a way that kind of
makes me question about just how
cerebral and just how much i know about
myself
yeah so what were you fighting against
it was
more that i presumed when i would reach
a setback like that
some serious trauma that
i've gone through periods of depression
and sadness and stuff like that before
and i just thought oh man my
constitution is not going to do well
with this kind of a setback
despite all of the stoicism and
fantastic guests i've spoken to on this
show and all the rest of it
i just presumed that i would i
didn't think i had this sort of makeup
that would deal with it fantastically
well
and honestly like a lot of it was
hard work and i can be proud of the
development in myself that i've done to
get myself to that point
but there was something else as well
there was another few gears inside of me
that i didn't know i was going to find
and um yeah i i didn't have
the world ending inertia that i
perhaps feared was going to occur and
very quickly was able to focus on doing
what i could do
um and you hear this all the time right
you hear about people who go through
tragedies and who end up using that as
the springboard for something even
greater
um and i it's kind of just a bit like a
fable that isn't it you just think uh
well yeah that's good for that yeah yeah
yeah it's also kind of good and bad
because it like that's one of the things
that is sort of a problem in
culture right now is the
inability for people to accept
themselves
just as people like everything has to be
this extraordinary
you know hero's tale and no one's
allowed to just like
be a person so so like it makes people
feel like if you're injured and you have
this achilles
uh you know time that you need to spend
kind of
just low-key relaxing there's this weird
feel because of sort of internet culture
in some way that's like well if you
aren't
using that as a springboard to change
your life then you're
a loser you know and it's like no it's
also okay just to sit and do nothing and
just
be a person and be all right for a
minute you know yeah that's a function
of seeing the highlight reel of
everybody else right that
totally totally almost any uh incident
is also a potential for content yeah
exactly exactly yeah so it's like unless
you're taking
a selfie whilst the operation's going on
and recording your podcast and then it's
got to be in the newsletter
um and everyone just feels like a budget
gary vee so
yeah yeah i get that very very much so
today i wanted to talk about
we've already had you on the show you're
episode like 12 and this is going to be
250 something so
everyone that wants to find out about
your approach is for meditation go back
and listen to that it's a fantastic
episode
but today your other i guess
internet commodity that you that you uh
travel in that you you end up shipping
is binaural beats
and it's something that myself and some
of the other guys i regularly have on
the show
we have played around with we use i know
johnny's a huge fan of brain fm he also
uses some of your tracks as well to work
to and to sleep to them for meditation
but i've never really heard anyone give
a breakdown of
what binaural beats are why they
exist what their effects are how they're
made all that stuff so i want you to
i want you to get yourself in to uh
kind of break down the fourth wall a
little bit about it so where do we begin
man absolutely yeah well thanks for
having me on and
i'm happy to dive into it with you well
i think that beginning we're just kind
of defining some terms
is useful because like meditation
dealing with anything that's sort of uh
effervescent or you know it's like it's
not a physical thing so it's it's
you know conceptual like audio is is a
bit harder to grasp
for some people so just sort of
introducing what the
the binaural beats are so first off
binaural means basically you know stereo
so uh monaural is like one single sound
source so if you think in your
headphones your
or whatever you've got a left and a
right headphone
that's uh you know left and right so
it's two by bi
uh and then aural you know so two sound
you know and a monorail would be a
single mono signal which is like
an old record player or something that
has like the horn the gramophone player
or just the horn coming out that's mono
that's one you know
but also all like voice recordings are
mono you know
um and for a bit of useless more detail
uh i will say that uh and most mono
sounds that you hear you know are then
they're split to stereo so it's the same
thing coming through
both speakers but it's just uh you know
it's still uh mono
anyway so then the beats uh part of
binaural beats so binaural is you know
two
audio signals and beats is beating
so in music uh there's a phenomenon
called beating and that is whenever you
have two audio frequencies which of
course all
sound and music are all audio
frequencies wherever you have two audio
frequencies that are
close together they vibrate because
sound moves in waves so if you think
about
all sound is like uh it's physical you
know so it's it's moving through
air so it's literally like uh you just
think of a wave going up and down and up
and down
and it's literally just moving through
air in a physical way it's breaking
through the air
as it goes and
um the speed of that vibration
of the wave so you know something very
uh a deep sound like bass from you know
like
your slam and house track that we
mentioned earlier um but more
particularly
the bass line that the deep you know
bass line you would hear that's kind of
hovering in the room during
you know amongst the kick drum that is a
really
really uh slow moving waves
wave and that's why whenever you're
standing next to a subwoofer you feel
air coming through it's because there's
like so much force
and it's so slow that it's literally
like as the wave goes up
and down it's like that negative space
is actually pushing like
physically pushing air through
is that that's why it happens yeah i
never realized that you can feel that
whenever you put your hand in front of a
little subwoofer you've got next to your
tv right
yeah totally it's just as the little
sort of those
puffs coming out yeah so it's literally
like the sound wave
is like pushing it's moving the air out
like that
um so then if you
as you start to move upwards and
frequencies so
this bass tom let's move up to think of
like something
like a high hat or even even higher
that's going to be really
fast so it's going to the sound wave is
going to be moving really really fast
and it's going to look like kind of
almost uh
you know crinkled or something like that
because it's moving so fast
and that's the high frequency right so
uh that's like
or even the highest note on a piano or
something is super fast so if you really
think about it
um like spinning something up whatever
it is doesn't have to be sound or music
or anything
if you if you have uh you know something
you spin it up it gets faster the pitch
kind of naturally rises you know on
anything like that
it's just the same property the physical
property that's happening
in music and sound so um in
on back to the piano you think about the
piano
uh so this beating thing the notes on
like a piano for example or a guitar are
all
very close to each other like the
frequencies the vibrations they're very
close
uh and so if you play like a white and a
black key and a piano that are right
next to each other
you think about that you hear that sort
of wobbling that like
that's the beating because their
frequencies are
are tuned individually and one key is
tuned to that note the key is tuned to
to this other note
but they're very close together because
on a piano of course you start from the
lowest note to the highest note it goes
left to right
and they just kind of with each key
they're incrementally tuned a little
you know a few uh you know hertz higher
and higher and higher and so you've got
this
nice uh system that you can play on that
sounds good
um but if you play two notes that are
right next to each other that are you
know
minor and and major then you're going to
hear that beating because they're
they're they're so close to each other
that they're actually those sound waves
are kind of
interfering with each other so if you
think about that
up and down wave thing happening well
now you've got two notes
so you put two of those right next to
each other and they're
fighting for space in air so you think
about that subwoofer
pushing the air out so since all notes
are moving through air you've got these
two notes that are kind of fighting for
space they're cycling at a similar free
speed in frequency and so they're
colliding
and so as they're colliding that's what
creates that that wobbling sound
so when again on the piano you hit two
notes black and white key right next to
each other you hear that wobble
that's literally the two frequencies
fighting for space
and that's what creates the the beating
because they're fighting in physical
space
you know for for a room and so that's
what creates that sound that's called
the beating
so binaural beats is
two you know basically one headphone in
one ear one in the other and then
beating
is the idea of two frequencies uh
creating that
wobbling sound by being very close to
each other
and kind of fighting against each other
so that's just to define terms
for binaural beats the of just the
actual terms
now the actual functional process of the
tracks themselves
um this is a little bit more detail
about trying to make it as succinct as
possible
so you know the overall intended effect
is to be able to listen to these tracks
and change
the way that you're feeling change the
way that you're thinking in the way that
your mind is operating so you can
with intentionality of which track that
you use kind of coerce your brain
into a different zone so that would be
either something relaxation
you know uh creativity extreme
heightened perception and focus
sleep meditation just general kind of
alertness
but still feeling calm these kind of
different states that we go in
throughout the day you know wherever you
sleep
you're obviously uh very relaxed and
whenever you're
in the peak point of your day in the
afternoon you're drinking coffee you've
just worked out
that's one of your brain is firing
you're not in the flow state per se but
you're like in the alpha beta range
where you're you're really keyed up um
and then you know
a high performance level flow state is
like the the highest level of the brain
so throughout the day we move through
all these different
brain wave states and those are really
quickly
uh delta theta alpha beta and gamma so
that's from
lowest to highest um now
uh what's interesting is that then
these okay so in our brains
the way that thoughts and these brain
wave states
are defined is basically our brain is a
collection of neurons
it's a bunch of uh and you please stop
me at any time if this is if i'm
getting before and keep going this is
what we want to know okay
okay okay i'm trying to cut it down as
much as possible so
you're just trying to explain the single
most complex object in the entire
universe to us and how it relates with
sounds that go into our ears
well one of my favorite things about the
brain is it spends its entire existence
trying to make itself realize things
which is just really bizarre
so anyway uh you know so we
our brain is a collection of neurons and
by
in our brain operates on electricity and
so
the way we have thoughts or the whole
subsystems and different
areas of the brain work at all is that
those neurons
they fire an electrical signal from one
neuron to the next neuron
upon a little road called a synapsis and
that's basically the synapses
connect our neurons together throughout
the brain and there's like a you know
a billion ish or whatever or two billion
the trillion
who knows they're always raising that
number of how many neurons are in the
brain
and so whenever we think there's a
series of
neurons fire electrical signals through
our synapses
to these other neurons and so on and so
on and different areas of the brain
kind of uh they fire to each other and
it creates this interesting little dance
and those the the the speed
and frequencies of those electrical
signals moving throughout the brain
and the neurons firing are called brain
waves
so that's where we get the term brain
waves this is literally like the same
just as you think of audio waves it's
like these rolling waves of electricity
firing to the brain and those are the
brain waves so that's the damage
uh delta theta alpha beta gamma this is
the brain weight so is it would you be
able to say that the brain waves
are like a an aggregate of the
individual firings moving in a
particular pattern that commonly goes
together
yes exactly exactly yeah we got it
right right exactly so um so the idea
with um with binaural beats is to be
able to
try and affect what brainwave state that
you're in
on demand and so
the concept behind the actual audio
tracks
is to put one tone one of those
those tones in one ear at a particular
frequency so in the left headphone
you're going to have one particular
frequency
then in the right headphone you're going
to have another
particular frequency just a tone that's
going
now the difference in hertz between
those two tones
is going to be the same difference
of of hertz that your
that the um the speed of a particular
brainwave state
operates at so
okay so like a a for example for a theta
state and whenever the electricity the
neurons are firing it's moving through
the brain
that's generally happening at the speed
of four to eight hertz
somewhere in there ish uh and so
whenever we get more excited we get more
the brain
gets more amped up we're processing
faster then that speeds up to you know
8 to 13 hertz or something like that and
it kind of continues to increase
in these these bands that they've
labeled uh
you know these different things so let's
just make it really simple so
we think of theta and let's call it four
hertz
right so our we're very relaxed we're
almost this is almost like a meditative
type of state that we're in
with theta we're super calm uh just kind
of
uh consciousness is very placid and open
and everything
and so our brain waves are firing
signals slowly and calmly
and think of four hertz so it's just
this very slow
kind of boom whoa whoa that's the
the audio wave the subwoofer in the
brain moving up and down
so what we'd want to do to to replicate
that with the binaural beat
is to put one frequency in the left ear
let's call it
100 hertz so that's that's the tone
that's the kind of like
the crispest part of a kick drum just
for any audio engineers out there
kind of 100 hertz um
then in the other ear the other
headphone we're going to put
104 hertz
so just making it plain and using the
metric system
well with 100 and then 104.
so by putting 100 hertz in one ear 104
hertz in the other ear
you think about what those two tones are
doing whenever you listen to them
together right they're creating the
difference that four hertz because
they're so close
they create that beating or that
wobbling type of sound right
and so in that creating of the four
hertz
vibration uh the idea behind binaural
beats is that then
the brain as it hears each of those
tones in each ear
is trying to kind of mathematically make
up the difference
between those two frequencies as it's
hearing those individual
audio tones
and in that it entrains that's why they
call binaural beats
brain wave in training music it's
because it's then the theory
is that it entrains the brain into
that theta state so the brain waves
start sort of replicating
and sinking into the groove of the
frequency that you're hearing
and then ideally your your consciousness
is then shifted
into that particular brainwave state
can we hear something that is that
particular
theta that that bottom end one yeah
we'll draw let's let's play this uh
this track called uh opening i
that subtract its theta and we'll just
play 30 seconds of that or something now
okay and we're back and i mean i feel
relaxed
um yeah so if you you can hear in that
track you know and there's there's other
things going on so we can hear the
vibrating tones
but of course um in these tracks of
course
whenever you find these you'll see that
they're also accompanied by
other musical elements to make them
musical to make them
uh not just this technical sort of thing
that's happening
and depending on the artist you can
really create
a lot of emphasis so sort of just the
beating tones are sort of the bare
minimum to get the function going
also as a side note just to further
illuminate the conceptual nature of this
uh isochronic or like that's a term for
monophonic beating as well so something
that
their particular objects have the
propensity to beat on their own even
though they're just
a single object because of their
physical character so
a gong so that's exactly where i'm going
so you think about
whenever in a buddhist temple there's a
giant gong there and before they sit
down to meditate they hit that sucker
and he goes
well think about that sound it's going
it's the same thing it's the exact same
thing
so that's the beating right um so you
can take just that that raw
functional nature of it and then based
upon the you know whatever the artist's
uh talent or or purpose is you can then
really
scale that up to make it much more
nuanced
and succinct and impactful and
so you'll add and of course priority one
is listenability
so you have two tones you can add some
people usually put kind of textural
ambient sounds on top of them
to kind of give it a further uh relaxing
sound and also in ambient music
one of the points there is that you
don't want rhythmic
moments plotted in time per se because
you want it to be kind of off the grid
you don't want the listener
to be even if we're not doing it
consciously we subconsciously when we
listen to any music
pay attention to the rhythmic nature of
things and if we hear
you know one rhythmic sound that we hear
kick drum and then a snare we're gonna
expect to hear on the same beat
you know in the same rhythm another kick
or snare
and so on and so on we expect that like
imagine if you had your favorite hip-hop
track on
and every like seventh kick drum was
missing
you'd probably pull a hamstring or
something listen to that
maybe that's how i did my achilles yes
maybe i was listening to something that
was five to the floor or something
yeah because you lit you're expecting
this thing and it doesn't happen and
you're like oh you know
so we have this uh you know this and
even in you know cinematic music there's
you know very slow-paced rhythms we
still
expect this resolution to happen
musically so
anyway so in bottom beats there's not
rhythmic elements commonly because of
that you want the listener to
uh kind of lose track of time as it were
to further sink into
the actual effect of the thing so
musically there's generally just kind of
textual things
some people use nature sounds and stuff
i i use those sometimes
um but i i also tend to use
on some of the tracks i use my own uh
just kind of some
vocal drones but also a lot of other
kind of electronic sounds and various
things
uh and just to go a little bit into
my tracks in uh if you'd like i mean i'm
just kind of
talking endlessly here but please tell
me any at any point if there's any
any direction i'm going to go but no no
the only thing i was thinking before was
that i imagine you could
create a binaural beat without
any of the extra elements to it and it
might perhaps have the desired effect
but be so
unengaging that your thoughts might sort
of drift off elsewhere
without the in opening eye you've kind
of got these symbols and this sort of
stuff in the higher registers as well
that keep it more interesting i guess
yeah yeah and also just listening to the
tones yeah would
make someone feel like they're in like
space odyssey 2001
you know floating uh it's just it would
be very abstract and
and uh harder for people to relax into
it because they're focusing on just this
vibrating sound you know
uh it is interesting how the musical
quality works as a sort of observation
of the technical element in some way so
you sort of
you know aren't really focused on that
as much you're listening to the top
layer and the bottom layers doing all
the dirty work
you know that's funny you've trojan
trojan horst a really mindful
music set with something that sounds
nice on top
yeah that's right that's right um and so
in in my tracks you know i've spent
20 years you know as an audio producer
and
my whole life you know also in that same
time being a you know
a student of meditation and philosophy
and studying
consciousness just all the neurosciences
cognitive sciences you know
neuroscience consciousness psychology
philosophy of mind
and et cetera et cetera and music at the
same time those things are all
have always kind of woven into each
other they've been binaural beating
my whole life those two things um
and uh so i you know in my music
it's always the intentions have always
been uh something that fascinates me a
lot
is listener expectation the the
different things you can do
musically you know harmonically with
notes the arrival
the attention and relief and expectation
that people hear
and you have the the emotions and
feelings that arise
uh through listening to different you
know orchestrated melodies and sounds
also the way that you can make sounds
arrive and depart uh and very i call it
kind of musical sleight of hand
where it's like i uh have sounds that
take you know
in in my binaural beats which are 30
minutes to an hour to two hours long
you know some sounds will fade in for
10 minutes it takes that long for it to
go from silence to its peak volume
and at the same time other sounds are
fading out for 10 minutes
and so they're kind of crossfading and
there's a lot of that happening all at
once
and so before you even realize there's a
change you're already somewhere else
and then before you realize where you
are there's yet another change and
it's a real um sneaky and particular way
to keep people um
from really paying attention to time you
know and
and when you're timeless where are you
you're in the present right
and so by doing that it's a way to kind
of musically guide people to the present
moment
there's an also going on man yeah
there's a whole lot yeah and i could you
know of course nerd out on
on on it uh very deeply but
uh also i got really interested in
binaural beats whenever
like in the like early 2000s because i
was
always i've always been poking at my
brain to see what happens i'm just kind
of you use myself as a lab rat you know
for all sorts of different chemicals and
experiments and whatever
um but i really what got me interested
in them was reading some rather esoteric
uh writings on you know buddhism and
kind of fringe uh
meditation techniques and stuff way back
in the early 2000s ish
and uh maybe even right before that uh
but i remember
so one of the things i was reading was
that these some monks would sleep
on the right side on their right side if
they wanted to have
like a creative day the next day and
sleep on their left side if they wanted
to have a more
sort of systematic day so the idea was
that blood would saturate the right
hemisphere of the brain
and or left hemisphere and so on and i
don't know how much you know efficacy is
in that
that bit of thing but i'm sure the
psychosomatically that you're sort of
it's a nice placebo effect um
but i was reading things like that and i
was trying that and that was interesting
and then
i was also i've always been fascinated
with what particular frequencies
uh what they can do to the body so the
human body that is and so
you know if you play certain tones like
first off
if anyone doesn't think that tones can
affect the body let me remind you that
there are
uh weaponized audio devices that the
military and
and like kind of the militarized police
use
they're basically these giant well not
just not so
giant they sort of look like um what is
that dish
like a satellite dish and
uh they play a really high-pitched audio
frequency
that you can't even hear because it's
like above the range of human hearing
which is like around 20 000 hertz and
it's above that
but it's super loud and above that and
it literally
makes you pass out or in it or can cause
extreme discomfort headaches
disorientation
no way because yeah yeah you can
basically like fry someone's nervous
system
with super high frequencies so yeah are
those legal are they geneva conventioned
out or
yeah they they they are in america
anyway but you know this is kind of
wild west so who knows that's crazy
that's like the uh south pack episode
where they try and find the brown note
yeah exactly exactly that would be so
much more funny if they use that if they
could do that and sort of make people
poop their pants instead of
yeah passing out yeah totally i mean
because then at least it's hilarious
there's dogs in the nearby town when
they're playing that thing going
absolutely crazy having a party
man you know it yeah we're wanting to
you know crawl out of their their fur
so um yeah so you know these these
sounds you know sounds
really not only because they're just the
physical nature of them
um but also just the way that our our
body holds resonance as well so you know
you we like a kick drum
uh a bass line makes it like daft punk
makes anybody want to kind of move a
little bit
because of the bass is like literally
you know it's it's hitting your
there's a lot of research that shows
that like the base frequencies and the
rhythm
of like dance tracks the reason why
those rhythms and those temp those bpms
those like beats per minute
make you want to dance one of them is
because they're like higher than the
rate of resting heart rate
so if it's a little bit higher than your
heart rate it makes you want to kind of
match that
tempo you know if you listen to
something relaxing there's some samba or
something like that
it's like 60 beats per minute or
whatever
super relaxed can you explain why cardi
b's whap is done at 70 beats per minute
then
well that's maybe you should like put
wash some porn and then
we'll see if the rhythms in that match
the rhythms in the
in this in the track [ __ ] wap man
yeah i
am i always noticed that one of the
things i dj'd for
a short while um when i was younger and
even now i can tell the difference
between a dj who's playing at sort of
125 126 and 128 129
uh 128 being sort of the classic i guess
dance rhythm uh the pacing right
and um i went to go and see ben bowman
from anjuna deep
on the beach at dubai while i was out
there and the sun's setting over the
horizon
and he's playing at like 123 and it's
just so
cool super chill yeah it was beautiful
and that insight i even remember
thinking back then i was like this is so
slow but he's managed to get it right so
even
that that particular rhythm if he'd been
playing those tracks
pitched up to 128 or 129 it would have
given a very
different sort of sensation and i
suppose that we're talking here
about gradations of how music has an
effect on us right
like right cardi b's wipe had a
different effect on
me to the the music of
anjuna deep being played at sunset and
the rhythm is a part of that as are
obviously the lyrics as
is the kick drum and all the rest of it
but before we go on let's let's play
another one man
what should we listen to next yeah sure
so this one
uh let's go with uh this is kind of my
personal
favorite uh is one called luminosity
and this track is uh i had so many
people over the years
um we're kind of going out of order here
and just in the biography
and kind of the reason of all these
exist but
over the years i had a lot of people hit
me up asking me to make
tracks for like psychedelic journeys or
for you know like extended meditation
retreats or something like that
basically how to get into that deep deep
part of the mind and really have some
some scaffolding and guidance there
and so for just rather sort of
uh i would call them ethical reasons
i i didn't call them like music for
psychedelics or
music whatever yeah yeah because one i i
think it's a little corny and also
i never you know just kind of
philosophically i never want to be
instructing people to do things or
anything at all
much less you know uh trying to you know
influencing people so people do what you
want you know but
uh anyway so it's called music for deep
work as the collection
and you know and also it doesn't uh it
you know i think we can do deep work in
a lot of ways
you know with or without chemicals and
it's important to highlight that as well
so
uh this is one of the strikes and it's
luminosity
okay so um yeah you can hear that track
has
more pronounced kind of musical
qualities to it
that are still sparse and stretched out
uh but it is going
in that uh that theta range you know to
keep to getting that deep kind of
uh creativity very very calm relaxed
uh type of zone and i some of the tracks
this one uh being one of those i get a
little tricky with them because
i will take it from
one brainwave state and slide down
slowly over the course of the track
sometimes
because people are already kind of keyed
up as humans anyway they're already kind
of dialed up till and like tense and
weird and fidgety
and just stressed and you know we all
are over overly stimulated and
oversaturated
so kind of starting from one place and
then slowly have them sort of like
sinking down into the sand like as it
goes on
um which i don't know if i've ever
mentioned that publicly that i do that
sometimes before
cheeky cheeky gear sorry but it's kind
of like frogging boiling water
type yes exactly except for
it's a hot tub not a boiling pot hot tub
to cool
cool bath yeah exactly yeah yeah yeah so
um so anyway so sounds affect the body
and i've
been really fascinated with that you
know over my life and
there's a lot of research out there some
weirdo fringe
you know stuff some actually academic
over
what particular tones can affect the
body
in in what ways and there's like i mean
i have a huge
archive of research from over as i said
earlier you know the time that i was in
in my early 20s or late teens early 20s
i got
interested in this in the 2000 around
the year 2000
and i just started like researching and
reading and collecting these different
things and i would i'd make these audio
tracks
with different frequency frequencies to
kind of see how they made me and other
people feel
and it just kind of my interest in that
evolved from there
so i did make some binaural beat tracks
back then
uh and then i guess probably five or six
years ago
what was funny is that uh my friend
aubrey hit me up and was like hey i've
been
i want to try binaural beats you know
i've heard that they're really awesome
um but do you think like have you ever
made any and i was like yeah you know
like
i don't know 15 years ago and he's like
would you break down
like some and i said yeah sure sure so i
i made some
and i was just like just making them to
make them and
then i let him listen to them and he was
just like dude what the [ __ ] is this
this is crazy you know these
like this is like a like what's
happening
here and so in the course of me making
them
uh you know the last the 15 years of
compositional experience and music
production experience all
culminated in meditation you know just
familiarity with consciousness
and uh that ultimately also the
awareness
of the texture of my own mind in any
given moment you know i think
becoming acutely aware of that became
very valuable in making these tracks
and it's why they have kind of the one
of the reasons
why they have kind of the magical
quality that they do
uh is because through you know 20 years
of meditation
i've gotten to where i'm very aware of
like
how my consciousness is shifting in the
moment where it's at like
as i said you know the texture of mind
and
also i'm aware of when that's being
changed and influenced
and so increa in the creation of the
tracks i put a lot of detail a lot of
interesting little
you know uh tricky things in there like
i i mentioned to you
and i'm kind of tuning them all
musically
you know rhythmically the actual
frequencies themselves
until i feel that flow state shift in my
own consciousness
and it's not even necessarily like it's
not like a mixing issue
or a you know a spatial issue or a
particularly a harmonic issue it's more
of just
listening and getting like the kind of
the palette set
and then adding and moving everything
until
whatever way necessary until i feel that
shift within myself
and whenever i feel that flow kind of a
like hyper presence
portal open and dilate i'm like i got it
there there it is and so that's sort of
why all these tracks
have that quality to them is because i'm
literally like tuning them to my own
mind
until i feel them like um turn the key
you know and when they turn the key i'm
like
there it is now it's just a matter of
finishing it off is it a different
way to create a two-hour long binaural
beat
track that you're aiming to resonate
with your mind in a particular way like
if you're sat in the mixing studio
i imagine you must need to get yourself
in quite different places if you're
mastering down a hip-hop track or
something
no i mean what's funny about that is
that over
i don't know i've gotten to where over
the years
i'm very i'm kind of like a surgeon with
music i
got it's not that i'm not clinical it's
not i'm clinical about it in the sense
that i don't
have any feeling or care but i'm very
removed
from like being influenced by whatever
i'm listening to
generally uh i try and uh it's it's
because i sort of like want to remain
objective in the process and not
get like swept up and it's strange like
it's one of the confusing things about
like buddhism as well
is we'll talk about cultivating a
dispassion for
for everything you know even for
pleasure and be like why would i want to
not
want to feel pleasure you know it
doesn't make any sense but so i kind of
articulating that further it's like
it's like oh well you want to you can
enjoy the pleasure but you don't want
to to crave and desire and to want the
pleasure
or else it has control over you and it
becomes a point of suffering because
whenever that thing fleets as the all
things do
then you have a void and you seek you
know this pleasure again
you have the passion for the pleasure
you go look for it and you begin to
suffer and then that kind of daisy
chains on with all the elements of
suffering
so by cultivating a spacious dispassion
for
for pleasure then when a pleasure comes
you can deeply enjoy it and receive it
but still not be you know addicted and
have the craving that creates the
suffering that's kind of how i look at
music production
is like i have i have kind of a i have a
dispassion for it in the sense that i
hear
i'm here i receive it when it's
happening i
do instinctively and intellectually what
i know
needs to happen to it uh but don't get
caught up in
in all the human stuff with it i'm
absolutely adamant that cardi b
felt the same way when she was recording
definitely the lyrics
to what and megan the stallion she was
very very famous for her principle of
non-attachment
yeah she's well the track had quite an
effect on you
yeah i'm absolutely blown away by it man
i find it
i find that track particularly and then
the um associated social media furore
that came out after it to just be
fascinating
uh and that's a whole another discussion
that i think we could get into
but um it's a great track and megan the
stallion is amazing i heard her new
album is
if you want i don't know if you've heard
her album that came out last friday but
yeah i i recommend that yeah
so next what we've got next let's play
another song we've got uh
we've played the luminosity and opening
eye what else we got yeah yeah so i'll
we'll go into a yet another direction uh
i'll just wrap up that what i was
talking about uh
uh real quickly and that is you know so
i gave these
tracks to aubrey and he listened to them
and was like man this is amazing
and so as we kind of talked about him a
little bit further
we're like you know he's like maybe uh
maybe we should like
offer these to people we could sell them
put them on his website this is before i
even had like a store on my website
he said we could put them on my website
and see see who digs them
and so i did a you know did we did some
podcasts we talked about them
and they just like the response was just
crazy it was like
i never would have anticipated the
amount of feedback and like response and
and stuff that
listeners had to to the binaural beats
so it started where i just
i think it's kind of since then i've
never not got a message
uh you know a day without someone saying
dude i love these are i listen to these
every day thank you you know
what's the most common usage that you've
found people
use them for i think two things either
meditation or for focus
so and we'll get to the focus thing
right after this
um and so yeah man uh it was
really fascinating i ended up licensing
those to on it you know and so that was
that was cool like they became you know
a nice uh
kind of fixture within the the on it you
know world and expand out from there and
then
then i just kind of continued in my own
way to like you know okay well i made
those
let me continue on to the different you
know um
intentional purposes of each one that
people are hitting me up and asking for
and also
uh i'm constantly my curiosity
and didn't drive to kind of uh
i don't know i guess improve upon a
craft and like hone in
something just as natural and so i'm
always like well let's see if i can
how powerful and potent can i make these
dudes i mean
i i still say that the release into now
meditation series that you did which
will be linked in the show notes below
is still my favorite guided meditation
for anyone who wants to take it to the
next level it's
in my opinion it's a it's a big ask for
a beginner um
because the sessions are like half an
hour but if you've spent a little bit of
time
and you've built up a base level of a
habit like that thing just
super over space of six weeks just
totally supercharges you
there's not a single person that i've
said you need to go and get this to kind
of level up your meditation game
and they haven't come back and gone like
what the [ __ ] was that
oh man that's awesome to hear thank you
thank you one of my
one of my buddies did it um and i think
he he really struggled for the first few
this is a compliment i think
but he struggled for the first few days
to stay awake um during them and he
found himself just immediately going to
sleep even if he
slept perfectly fine the week before
this is also a friend
to whom i sent sam harris explaining
determinism and
our lack of free will and it sent him
into a two-week spiral of depression
so i've done quite a lot i've done quite
a lot to this friend over the last year
so luke i want to apologize to you again
buddy
i didn't mean also man luke check out
compatibilism that's another
that's maybe that'll be better with you
that is the answer yeah
um sorry i'll interject that man there's
a
recent daniel dennett paper that he just
published on
expanding free will have you seen this
no
i'll send it to you i'll send it to you
once i'm done and anyone that wants to
to read it it's available for free if
you just search expanding free will
daniel dennett
on google really like fascinating study
i was reading that sleep deprived on the
way back from dubai
and that made for like that was the
visual equivalent of binaural beats i
think as i'm reading this
these words and i'm trying to work out
what the hell is going on
um but yeah man releasing to now let's
say anybody that wants to kind of really
up level their meditation game just go
and do that over the space of six weeks
you will uh you will change an awful lot
about how you see meditation i think
oh well thank you man thank you it's
it's interesting is that again i made
that you know
five six years ago and people still
you know are are you know supporting and
very interested they're always coming to
it you know
and uh it's interesting to me i actually
went back and listened to some of it
because i was like well it's been five
years like you know
that was my first attempt at ever like
teaching anything
and so i was just like i hope it still
holds up and it was kind of refreshing i
clicked through some of it
and i was like ah okay it's still it's
still pretty so embarrassing about that
old
old world yeah um
also as a funny side note on daniel
dennett uh i've been
his book consciousness explained i got
in the late 90s i think and that was a
big impact on me whenever i was a
teenager
and i really liked that one and i
actually emailed tufts university
whenever i was like
1920 or something and asked if i could
come be
a free like an intern or assistant for
daniel dennis
and uh yeah they didn't reply but it's
been but
little did daniel didn't know that he
just turned down the opportunity to get
free binaural beats for life
exactly exactly yeah i think he's more
interested in
sailing and yeah out on the coast
indeed so one of the things i've noticed
is that the two
the area the two areas that you
mentioned were deep focus
and uh meditation so quite
mindful quite open quite present but you
mentioned that we've got these higher
higher ranges as well that we go into in
terms of frequencies is that something
that
you just don't think people really need
or is it something that you actively
tend to avoid in terms of
creating binaural beats no no it's um
it's an important one it's one of the
most popular so that's what uh it's a
good
primer to move into the next thing um
and so
a lot of i guess a lot of the work i do
generally through the meditation course
or my podcast or
you know the music a lot of it is about
trying to get
people to calm down you know what i mean
calm down
relax be present and sort of wake up to
their own
awareness uh that's what a lot of my
stuff does
so um also the other the counterpoint to
that to balance that
is the extreme focus the flow state the
gamma state so the gamma state
is the highest state you know it's is
you know heightened perception
flow kind of existence mind
and so uh yes that is a very a lot
faster of a vibration that's generally
what you know 40 to 60 hertz some people
clock it at about a hundred um but
i think that 40 to 40 ish to 60 ish is
right
just the way that i've felt whenever
i've experimented with them
so on the first set of binaural beats i
made which i mentioned to you that i
i shared with aubry there was a track on
there called gamma flow
and that was like basically you know
it's pretty self-explanatory but
uh it was meant to be like the you know
kind of
that was a collection you know so that
you get all sorts of different tracks in
that
that collection and that was the flow
state track and that one i think has
been
one of the most popular of all of
all time uh because it's really
apparently has had a
profound effect on listeners helping to
get into their
their concentration state and their flow
state and the amount of people that have
emailed me over the years have said hey
i wrote my entire book to this i wrote
my
[ __ ] yeah like i listened to this on her
piece people have sent me like
screenshots of their
their apple like not you know on itunes
like the
amount played like the play count you
know
here's gamma flow played you know 230
times i'm like
230 times that track's half an hour long
you know
and like yeah i listened to it for a
year and repeat while i was finishing my
phd thesis or whatever
and it's just like endless endless yeah
and so uh that track people
really really like for flow state and
um yeah so there's that one and then
after that because people
dug that so much i ended up making the
second volume
of binaural beats i released with
library
uh are all flow state tracks so it's
four different flow state tracks
so we can play some of gamma flow right
now yes
all right so um so that's that one yeah
and that it's pretty
uh minimal and spacious but you can
uh you'll probably feel that flow
happening and
you know these are of course you know 30
second dish samples that we're playing
here and
the reason the tracks are so long is
that you know in general in play length
from 30 minutes to two hours is because
the
idea is you know the kind of longer you
listen to it
the longer your brain you know has a
longer time has to kind of
sink into it get into the zone i think
that generally they say it's about you
know
at least kind of two to four five
minutes to really
enter the open the door you know and now
it's another
kind of five minutes to get further into
sort of like meditation you know further
into it and then so on and so on
and once you can hit the 10 to 20 minute
mark you're
you're really sailing what's the um it's
like a whooshing sort of
air wind sound in that
gamma flow track what's that yeah oh
that's
that's kind of um that's meant as a
uh the stereo effect to really
confuse time so and it actually is the
recording of of air that i took
it's like the coast recording of the
waves how did you record that
yeah very sneakily very very quick to
creep up on it right because
yeah real vigilant real quiet quiet room
and a powerful microphone
um you ever speaking of that as a side
note you ever heard of an anecdote
chamber before yes but i can't remember
what it is
it's like a sound soundless room
so there's basically it's designed
inside to where
there's no reflections so basically
whenever we hear sound we're generally
hearing the reflections of sound not the
actual sound itself
so if you're in a room and you talk
you're not really hearing your voice
you're hearing your voice bounce off the
wall behind you
and off the ceiling and off the floor
and so forth uh but in one of the that's
why music studios have sound
absorption and panels because it wants
to break those reflections and those
resonances
so that the microphone can actually
record the source instead of the the
sound of the room
also interestingly enough since we're in
a sound wormhole
every space has its own frequency so
the uh the square
footage of a room and the materials the
room is made out of like the the area
of the room it itself has
a tone so if you're when you're talking
in your room
the the width and length and height of
the room itself and as i said the
the material of the wall so how the
reflections are coming
actually have its own tone so if you you
speak in one room it's gonna there's a
different
kind of passenger in there with you and
that's why
auditoriums and music halls are very
precisely
you know designed so that they don't
have that or they mainly they have an
amplifying effect but no real resonant
effect
i remember once in one of the nightclubs
that we were working out of it had a
huge back wall so you can imagine it's
got this high high ceiling and then
halfway down the room this high ceiling
chops down into a low ceiling that
continues to go
and the speakers at the front were
throwing toward the back
and upon refurb the guys the builders
had taken down this
huge frame it was like a image
sort of post it kind of like a post like
a thick poster at the back
on this main back wall and they'd taken
those down
and the guys sound checked and threw the
speakers back on in this new
configuration
and it sounded so quiet like they were
blasting these speakers to hell and it
sounded super super quiet
and what we realized was that that back
wall the
painting poster thing had actually been
a bunch of
conical uh sound absorbers and what you
were getting was the sound being thrown
from the front
hitting itself on the way back from the
wall and getting almost completely
zeroed out
which was insane you could turn it up
super super loud
and it would just sound like nothing
because the sound hit the back wall hit
itself
and then just killed it yeah that's like
a l like a low frequency oscillator like
an lfo
you'll see that in on synthesizers or
and or even like a wah pedal
like uh for guitar like jimi hendrix you
know that's
like an lfo so it's like creating a
subsonic sound
that actually so subsonic sounds are
frequencies that are below
even like you know human hearing like
weibull hence the term subsonic
and they're so deep and you know the
wave is so big that it
pushes everything like sounds out of the
air and so with a wall pedal that's why
it sounds wah-wah whenever you move the
pedal is because it's literally creating
like a break
you know in the actual sound or even
like a tremolo effect when you hear
something
going like like statically that's
because it's just
like literally there's a subsonic
frequency pushing out
all the audio there in a rhythmic way
it's like
just blasting it out so it cancels it
out there's a
a club in glasgow called the sub club
and
that has a subsonic dance floor so it's
got sub-sonic
speakers built into the actual dance
floor itself
so when you have bass tones that come
through that you feel it through your
feet
nice that's very cool let's say elf
don't drive elephants man
you know they elephants they can send
i read something sometime is that they
can like hear each other from miles away
because you know a base travels
obviously and they can send
like sounds that are so deep that the
base will just travel like a mile or
something
and of course they got big-ass ears and
so
that i just think it's so interesting
for an animal it's of course their size
and like their
resonance there's just they're a big ol
that's a big double bass right there but
like
just an animal being able to send that
deep of a base sound is such a
peculiar it's like what if you could
emit a subwoofer sound from your body
upon demand yeah that's like kind of
what they're doing it's sort of
sort of wild some of the blue whale
noises and stuff as well those can go
for
absolutely i know obviously that sound
conduction in water is significantly
better than it is through air
but totally yeah that goes for forever
right
yeah yeah yeah yeah um okay so i don't
remember where we were really
um gamma flow we did that one yeah
all right so yeah we did that one um and
uh
yeah so that's a really great one your
people people would dig that in the
second collection
was for you know all for flow and so
since then um i've mainly created tracks
that are for you know meditation for
relaxation
for you know the the deep work and so on
and uh uh
i think that you know moving on to
perhaps the last piece
is one for sleep so that's another thing
that people hit me up so much about and
i got so many messages of people saying
like hey you know i've been
been working like uh this is pre
uh lockdown times but people are saying
like i've been
working 10 hours a day and going to you
know like university at night time and i
have two kids
and i'm like on the verge of just a
mental breakdown and like i'm so
fried and freaked out by the end of the
day i can't sleep
and the only thing i've been able to
sleep is someone hooked me up with
one of your tracks and this has been
helping me like de-escalate and get to
sleep at night so just thank you
whatever i have gotten that message you
know like
a hundred times and it made me realize
like okay people need
something for sleep and then you know of
course as tends to happen in this weird
world as i started thinking about that
of course i started having people
message me requesting like hey
you ever thought about making tracks for
sleep yeah okay that's clear
what is next um and so i made yeah i
made
the next the tracks for sleep uh and
these are
really deep these are delta tracks so
these are
you know to guide the the mind literally
to like dreamless sleep
uh complete like lack of body awareness
type of zone and obviously people aren't
going to be sleeping with headphones in
most times um but i made the tracks like
two hours long
so the idea is that you can you get in
bed
you know and then you start listening to
one of these maybe you're reading or
something like that and
then in that hour that you're kind of
like chilling out before you actually
try and sleep you're
already listening to that getting into
the zone and then
you know once you you turn the lights
off and probably take the headphones off
then you're going to be like right there
so it can help you it's kind of like a
sleep
primer is how i pretty much did but but
yeah
but there's a lot of uh it's interesting
they're actually a lot of
people out there that do use like
there's headbands with like
uh your earbuds built in muse
the guys who do that portable e
k e g ekg the brain sensing headband for
meditation
so i just got popped by one of their ads
uh
the other day and they've created
something that must
track your brain waves or your your
brain states while you sleep
yeah that's they're not i talked i know
ariel garten the founder of muse and she
was telling me
a while back like last year that was
their next
product so it's cool that it's it's
come to market man i've seen it but yeah
you're totally right the the world
for for this stuff um this
state app which is by brian mckenzie
which is a breathwork
um application and then the silent mode
which is a face mask with inbuilt
headphones
and accompanying music
to do breath work too and then there's
wearables like
muse that were originally for seated
meditation with audio feedback
and now we're going into brain tracking
whilst you're asleep
and like the wearables market is just
like it's going in
all directions at once yeah yeah it's
funny is i actually don't
like any of that stuff people they send
them to me but i'm just sort of just
like
uh i don't need another like band to
strap
on i keep don't use the word strap i uh
got so many i have three already um
yeah being honest man i've i've
struggled with with pretty much
everything
that i've tried i keep my whoop strap on
as an activity tracker
um but uh we were talking about this
while i was away
it really doesn't feel like anyone's
kind of captured the wearables market in
the same way if you think about the kind
of leap
that apple had with the iphone and just
how much of a
chasm there was between that device and
everything else that's before it
and i don't think we've had that yet
with wearables you've got the apple
watch but a perfect example of this rory
sutherland's
modern wisdom regular modern wisdom
guest he
suggested that he thinks if steve jobs
was still around the apple watch
wouldn't be made
he thinks it's too complex too
unintuitive too highly priced and too
user inefficient
um and i'd never heard it before but i
actually thought yeah do you know what
it is i
i buy everything from apple like they
bring something out i upgrade my laptop
i upgrade my phone
fairly regularly i've never had any
desire to buy an apple watch
and i think he might be right with that
and the
the idea of wearables is right but i
think the execution
thus far pretty much industry-wide is
just a bit lacking
yeah i agree i'm not i'm not a fan enjoy
i mean i have an apple watch
uh but i i'm not like uh grudging
yeah yeah i like it but i only wear it
whenever i go out or
you know go running or something like
that um but i'm just don't care about
like data you know like i just
i i know every teach their own of course
and for some people it's very useful
um but to me uh there was a like uh
there's a the show shit's creek i don't
know if you've ever seen that it's quite
funny but
dan levy is like going on a hike with
his his
boyfriend and he's like oh my
my apple watch is dead or whatever and
he's like there's no point in even
hiking
it's not like i'm not getting the track
and like i don't care
we'll do it again tomorrow did you see
so one thing
that i will say that was a fairly big
game changer
is for me knowing how much time i've
been asleep
i'm aware that there's a margin of error
here but the
waking up on the morning and being able
to look and know
that i got seven hours of sleep or seven
and a half or eight or eight and a half
or
five um as opposed to the old world
before wearables
which was just going to bed at a time
and then waking up at a time and not
really knowing
um that that has definitely informed
my the way that i operate a lot a lot
more effectively
and i can compensate for sleep debt and
and kind of play around with things
but you're right if you're not drilling
into the data i think a lot of devices
almost all of them
put out so much more than you need and
then unless you act on the data that you
get from a wearable
like what's the purpose of it it's just
like this sort of mass but
masturbatory game of
producing data for the sake of indexing
it
exactly exactly man yeah it's further
distraction they might have been in a
lot of cases
again for me but you know some people
i'm sure it's incredibly useful
i have had a lot of people send me
speaking of uh
you know things like muse and uh i think
whoop that has
some similar data just showing your
you know uh you know neural feedback or
also your
your kind of real-time heart rate or
whatever change
is people have sent me screenshots where
they're like man this is
before like this is a six-month
kind of like a shot here of
before i started listening to you know
you're using your meditation course for
binaural beats
and then after and like look at the
difference and it's been like
it's crazy when people send them to me i
should actually try and ask if i should
put those on my site or something
but they like it's just like a complete
like
you know inverse it's like a total
difference it's really
really cool to see that's crazy i've got
uh joel jameson
from eight weeks out he works with a lot
of ufc fighters getting them down to the
right weight but he's also one of the
world experts in hiv training
literally probably number one on the
planet i've got him on the show later
this month
and i'm gonna bring up the binaural
beats stuff with him because
him affecting people's hiv in a uh
appropriate way is pretty much what he
spends his time doing
and hiv is an indicator of relaxation
uh inversely you want a high hiv and a
low resting heart rate
um optimally but yeah that's that's
definitely one of them and when you
think about
what most of the recovery strategies
for athletes are doing what they're
trying to get them to do is just get
into a parasympathetic
state right any anyhow is it by
massage is it by going on a recovery
walk
in nature like is it by sleeping more
whatever it might be just trying to get
that hiv up and that resting heart rate
down
so yeah man i think i'll tell you what
why don't we
won't we listen to uh it'll be into the
void
um oh yeah is that the sleeper yeah
no that was lunar flow oh well you're
messing me up with the names now why
don't we listen to luna flow
okay and so then now also i think we're
in the same a good neighborhood and of
course time is
shrinking here so uh we can move into
into the void
which that is also another uh
deep delta track as well so it's kind of
a good companion this is from the first
collection
way back when um but i think this is the
one i think aubrey is called the dry
float
he's like it's like being in a float
tank but not
in the tank so this is the end of the
void track
okay and then coming out of that one i
think just you know with a few minutes
remaining touching quickly on some of
the research
around the stuff is important because
you know some people
are willing to just try a binaural beach
or something and see if it works for
them and i okay cool i like this
and it makes me feel a certain way some
people
uh are a bit resistant to it because
they're like okay this this is
a little skepticism which i think is
healthy um
ultimately i at the end of the day i say
with anything like that you know just
give it a shot and if it if it works for
you then cool if not
then uh then that's cool too uh but
there there's a lot of
uh research and increasingly so in
uh over the last few years even they've
become very popular
and uh for treating anxiety
and different traumas and kind of going
through traumas and things like that but
really for treating anxiety and trying
to
get people out of their even in a
clinical state of uh
of dealing with anxiety so one case in
particular that i enjoy that i was
actually a part of was
a research uh team in australia
in one of the universities two actually
or two uh which
unfortunately now i can't recall which
one it was because it's been
a year or two since i worked with them
but
um one of the major ones and so
they had a neuroscientist there that
was basically playing my tracks and i
created some actual
test tracks so they you could use
um kind of a control uh study
thing going on so something did you make
a binaural beat that wasn't a binaural
beat
yes yes so i made one with just
the musical elements and then one with
the musical elements and the tones
so they had like a controlled track
going on so they would put
people in there mainly people that were
you know struggling from psychological
issues
or anxieties whatever it might be put
them in the fmri scanner which is just
kind of a
brainwave reading machine we'll call it
that
and they would then monitor kind of how
their mind was reacting and how their
rate was reacting to it
and they showed you a very clear success
uh
through that brain imaging that the
track with the tones was affecting
you know the brain the way it was
supposed to in the sense of creating
relaxation slowing down the brainwave
padding patterns in the firing of
neurons so it's very very fascinating i
think that there
a lot of them in the academic sense have
been used for or have been
gaining a lot more traction for use in
uh in therapy sessions and stuff like
that and just general
overall kind of wellness for people who
are suffering
psychologically and kind of getting that
recovery in that's the
i guess the acute state change
um have we had a look have you had any
research to do with the trait change
other than yeah people sending you their
heart rates
yeah steadily decreasing over a six
month period
yeah there there have been several
studies of you know uh
selections of people who have kind of
been interviewed and taken readings and
in different data points and so forth on
their we're kind of resting levels of
stress and
and uh anxiety and whatever and and then
kind of use the tracks over a course
of time and then gone back and gone and
for you know more testing and monitoring
and so forth and shown
improvements and a reduction they're all
based on anxiety i think that's freaking
at the funding for
studies like that uh improvements on the
reductions of of their anxiety and kind
of their resting r rates and things like
that so
yeah it's it's all it's all interesting
yeah and i i like reading about those
things now
now and again but uh i think for me for
stuff like that
uh i'm mainly just kind of like you know
you could go read a bunch of
reports it's kind of i think i feel like
that was supplements too where it's like
you can read all about them or you could
just take one and see how you feel
and that again if you could bottle the
placebo effect you'd have
the most powerful effect in all of
pharmacology right
so yeah the the point is whatever works
for you works for you
and the mode by that happening
kind of is a little bit irrelevant so if
someone's thinking
that sounds good corey you've sold me on
binaural beats mate
what is your suggested dosing
is it more effective with speakers if
they've got good quality speakers or
with headphones and how often and etc
yeah definitely with headphones uh that
how often you can listen to them that's
up to you you know
how often you want to try and induce the
effect
i i listen to them during meditation a
lot of them are made for meditation
you know uh and it's very viable and
given that they're 30 minutes long it's
like you don't have to worry about a
timer or anything you just turn it on
and you know when the track's done
you're done
um and also if you're i think another
valuable time is that uh you know i've
had a lot of people reach out to me and
say that whenever they're
feeling kind of like in a crisis mode of
just like really overwhelmed really
stressed with work or
or relationship or whatever and they're
in that kind of like panicky like ah
that
that state to drop one on to remember to
use them then and drop one on just kind
of
lay down and take a little 10 minute
chill you know very useful in times like
that as well
um so apparently if you're writing a
book or working on your phd then
the game is very valuable but yeah
i was listening to adam gasoli who's a
neuroscientist
on um sam harris's podcast the other day
and he has got stage three
he's going into stage three fta approval
for brain training
games that are made to four
single focus um specifically to be used
to combat add
but these games would actually require a
prescription
for you to get them which i thought i
don't understand like it's just a game
but
as with many things something that can
cause a positive
change can also cause adverse reactions
if not used properly or supervised or
blah blah blah
but i wonder if down the line we'll see
prescriptions written or perhaps at
least doctors recommending binaural
beats as part of a
recovery protocol for someone who's post
surgery or ptsd
or anxiety depression any number of
psychological issues yeah a lot of
therapists recommend them already for
just for people that are kind of dealing
with just mental
health challenges you know depression
anxiety as you said you know ptsd
things like that um yeah they're just
sort of they're like hey
take listen to one of these and call
calm in the morning you know
i love it man i absolutely love it look
cory it's been awesome to have you on
two and a half years dude it was very
well worth the wait
yeah it's crazy how time flies when
you're in the present
absolutely uh people want to check out
your stuff where should they go
uh corey allen.com this is c-o-r-y-alan
dot com it's all there the binaural
beats they're releasing to now of course
my podcast of course astrology go and
check it out yep
yep it's all there peace dude thank you
so much for today
yeah thank you
you